[Music]
eric's in new york city hey eric what's
up
how you doing dave better than i deserve
man how can i help
yes um i
have credit card debt about 25 000
and two of them total 20 000 my credit
union is offering
a 1.99
uh to and i was thinking about
refinancing it
uh those two larger debts because it's
about four hundred dollars in interest
that i'm paying every single month while
i'm doing the baby steps i'm on baby
step one
so you owe you
you owe forty thousand dollars on
plastic
no i owe twenty five thousand on plastic
oh twenty five seven
right two of them total twenty i got you
okay and you're gonna you're gonna
refinance 20 of the 25
right okay and uh
what do you make a year
100 okay over 100 you know it's odd this
is the same conversation we were just
having a minute ago but he was on the
investing side and you're on the debt
side
you can do this if you want to do it
here's the danger
you're going to think you actually did
something
you think this is a big deal
you don't have a 400
problem my man
you have a 25 000 problem
when you address the 25 000 problem with
the idiocy spending you've been doing
like you've been in congress on plastic
when you address that deep down in your
soul you're going to get out of debt
really really fast on twenty five
thousand making a hundred
you're not going to be in debt very long
interest is not your problem
but if you wanna lower the interest
it'll help you a tiny bit here's the
deal five percent of you getting out of
debt is refinancing this 95 of you
getting out of debt is you're looking in
the mirror and getting pissed off
and chunking on this thing and beating
the snot out of it because
mathematically 95 of this is not going
to be an interest problem mathematically
this is going to be youth chunking money
on this because you're mad you're sick
and tired of being sick and tired i'm
not living like this anymore
you are 95 of the secret sauce that that
level of ah
you hearing me dude
yes so how long would it take if i just
left it
two months longer
you saved two months
i might have missed that by a few days
one way or another but my point is 400
is 4 800 a year
and you're gonna be out of debt in a
year and so
uh you know we cut it in half because
halfway through the year you're going to
have the debt half paid down so it's not
4 800 a year you're going to save it's
going to be more like 2 400 a year in
this year that you get out of debt in
one year
and so you're saving 2 400 bucks 200
bucks a month at the end of the day and
how fast does how much does that apply
to a 2 500 oh i was right it's 10 there
we go look at that so yeah you know
so it's probably it's between a month
and two months you're going to say it's
okay to do it i'm not mad about you
doing it but what i don't want you to do
eric the thing people do with that
consolidation is they feel like they did
something and they think they fixed it
with this loan and you cannot borrow
your way out of debt
yeah i mean
that's what they're selling is saving
money and then you kind of lean on that
instead of the intensity that you're
talking about and you you have this
frustration like i gotta get out of debt
and then you think you did something and
then you look up a year later and you're
still in exactly the same place i got a
lot of lower payments you gave me a line
what's that he doesn't have an interest
problem he has an intensity problem
that's what you're teaching that's a
good line well you gave it to me
i didn't say it you said it i'll let you
have it take your notes over here folks
you can own it